for days the question has hung over this
simmering city
would monday jerusalem day to israelis
marking the start of israel's occupation
of east jerusalem
be the day of definitive violent
eruption
as the hours ticked by the answer came
repeatedly grimly in the affirmative
at six o'clock as threatened hamas
launched a long-range rocket attack
on jerusalem's outskirts
and by nightfall it was counting a
growing number of dead
including children as the israeli
military struck gaza
one blast in the northern city of beit
hanun killed nine people
including three children
children eight months old were killed
muhammad
who was getting married five days after
eid was killed
how is this a children's fault girls
between the ages of 7 and 9 have died
how is this their fault
we were just sitting outside the house
waiting for the call to prayer
hamas military sources told us they
believed israel was targeting a
palestinian islamic jihad fighter who
they said
had earlier fired an anti-tank missile
with an israeli jeep
narrowly missing its civilian owner
that attack coincided with the hamas
rocket strike on jerusalem
seven missiles fired one intercepted six
falling in open ground
israel's prime minister said that
crossed a red line
requiring a forceful response
we will not tolerate harm to our
territory to our capital to our citizens
or to our soldiers
here at texas will pay a heavy price
i tell you citizens of israel the
current confrontation may last for a
while
within one escalation but he who chose
to escalate
will fill our arms strike
israel for crossing the line with the
actions of its security forces in the
al-aqsa mosque compound
known to jews as the temple mount
they moved in in large numbers using
tear gas rubber coated steel bullets
batons and stun grenades for a second
time in three days the inside of the
mosque
became a scene of battle
al-aqsa and jerusalem are a red line
whoever bears all the consequences of
this dangerous zionist aggression is the
israeli occupation
this is why the situation is exploding
israeli officials said palestinians
triggered the violence with stone
throwing
palestinian witnesses blamed the
israelis for firing rubber-coated steel
bullets
from long range injuries quickly mounted
into the hundreds
the palestinian red crescent said its
own medics were among them
in the neighborhood of sheikh jarrah
where palestinian families face eviction
palestinian-israeli members of
parliament faced off against
representatives
of far-right israeli parties the israeli
jerusalem day march
was called off after the government
barred the usual route through the
muslim quarter of the old city
citing the risk of violence but through
the day
into the night that violence came anyway
that began with violence is now ending
in violence
a muslim holy month that began here with
simmering tensions has spread those
tensions
spreading into truly dangerous
territory now deep into the night waves
of rockets continued to be fired from
gaza
at the al-aqsa mosque the confrontations
flared again
setting a tree alight a violent day over
dangerous days still ahead harry fawcett
al jazeera
occupied east jerusalem